my name is Sam today we're talking to
Vinod Khosla the note is the founder of
Sun Microsystems and Khosla Ventures
he's been involved in the creation of
dozens of billion-dollar companies and I
think it's one of the most interesting
thinkers that I've ever spoken to about
how to build an ambitious company and
team and everything else you need so
thank you for taking the time to talk to
us today great to talk about it I want
to start with the very beginning and how
to think about the idea and the mindset
for a company one thing you've said
before that I really love is that
there's a huge difference between a zero
million dollar company and is you're a
billion dollar company and maybe you
could start with just explaining what
you mean by that to me when you set out
on a journey your mindset determines who
you bring on board how you approach it
what you setup what deals you do or
which investors you got in the road
revenue company if you think 0 million
you're thinking a certain way to
tactically achieve a small short-term
goal 0 million dollars you start
building from day 1 the company and the
people you'll need to build the company
one of the things people seldom realize
when they're starting up you you don't
ever plan what you're going to do you
build a plan to make to plan in who
helps in that planning as you plan
iterative life as you evolve your
strategy and your tactics that team
which I call the kitchen cabinet of a
company is the essence of what your
company will become so one of my
favorite tweets I like tweeting out is a
company becomes the people it hires not
the plan it makes and that's grossly
under appreciated and is the biggest
difference between the 0 million and the
0 billion dollar company the initial
people you hire and your experience it
is the initiative people you hire but
also how you approach the initial
tactics my other great analogy if you
have a large vision you're climbing
Mount Everest
it's never a straight line nobody's
climbed Everest in a straight line you
get to base camp you get to camp one
came to camp three camp four if you get
the right approach you keep your you're
obstinate about your vision which is
Mount Everest but you're flexible about
tactics as things change as you zig and
zag when you pivot these are all things
on the way to staying with the vision
now you can also do the same tactics
without worrying about the vision and my
big beef with a lot of investors is they
want revenue they want to meet plan as
opposed to collect assets for this
larger ascent to Mount Everest so you
can clearly set up base camp where you
get revenue stability cash flow
breakeven the ability to raise more
money in the wrong place if your goal is
to get to Everest but you still get the
revenue you might have 20 million 50
million hundred million of revenue but
it doesn't help you get to Everest or
you can take a little longer a little
harder get to the base camp that lets
you get the resources to keep the
journey to your vision there's a huge
difference in in the team is the biggest
difference but there's also strategy
differences when you by the way
investors in my view matter a lot in
this because you make short-term versus
long-term trade-offs what percent of
investors in Silicon Valley do you think
are good long-term company builders as I
get in a lot of trouble for saying this
or among friends I think 90% of
investors add no value
my assessment 70% of investors add
negative value to a company that means
they're advising the company in the
sport of team building to find for
entrepreneurs they're advising a company
when they haven't earned the right to
advise an entrepreneur so some of the
junior people here when they asked me
hey at this other firm people young
people are going on boards
avianna board i say you haven't earned
the right to advise an entrepreneur so
it's unfair to Darnell know just because
you got an MBA and joined a venture firm
doesn't mean you're qualified to advise
not from now the biggest piece of it not
the only way is have you built a large
company have you gone through how hard
it is how uncertain it is how traumatic
it is to go through and just this
morning I was talking to somebody about
how many times we almost worried about
making payroll at Sun how am I going
bankrupt plenty of times like more than
two yeah and there was a period there
was a three-month period where we almost
went bankrupt because we had a hardware
problem monitors vo buying from Philips
were breaking every 30 days I think
there was probably a month or two when I
the earliest I went home what's that 3m
and the latest I was back in the office
was 7 a.m. it just you know unless
you've got rent you felt that
gut-wrenching decision
you can't advise not if now I hate board
members who sit in a board meeting and
say oh can you improve quality and then
five minutes later can you ship faster
and five minutes later spend less money
and they've never gone through really
hard trade-offs and how uncertain that
is if you add more people and increase
your burn rate are you gonna improve
oryx
your chances of getting something out
these are very uncertain very hard cause
the biggest thing an artwork deals with
is rich risk to take one when you take a
financial risk of running lean when you
take a engineer up marketing risk of a
feature poor product when you take rich
risk do you want to take and it's like
whack-a-mole and ambiguity is so hard to
deal with but it's the essence and
frankly it's one of the areas where
aren't knows when they don't think about
what they actually need be
the wrong people see if somebody's never
dealt with this decision making under
ambiguity and then big company they're
not qualified to help you one of the
things I hate about board members is
when you're doing that making these
deciding which risk you want in the
stressful environment the thing you most
want as an entrepreneur is a board that
you feel is calming you down is
supporting you yeah it's not adding the
stress and most board members while
you're doing that just like tell you oh
you're gonna die like your company set
like the thing I hate the most is when
an old board member of mine used to send
me like press clippings of competitors
all the time yeah to like make a point
and you really just want someone is like
you got to take a hard risk here it's a
tough decision there look these things
are the things you're not qualified to
advise an entrepreneur on if you haven't
been through there is time when panic is
the appropriate response in a company
yeah one thing that I think I've noticed
entrepreneurs that are working on hard
ambitious companies really struggle with
its figuring out who to trust
for what advice so how do you think
about that so my big advice and the
first piece of advice I gave Joe Kraus
when he was starting excite was the
single hardest decision you'll make is
whose advice to trust on what topic so
the answer you know if you're 20 years
old do you ask your dad or your friends
or if you're a marketing problem do you
ask somebody somebody who's done
marketing at IBM they've never dealt
with things with market isn't
established it's incremental year to
year 5% improvement is what they're
shooting for they're not qualified to
invent whole new markets whole new
approaches to markets so those are
really hard decisions and that's where
nuanced advice of which employee would
be better you know the funny story
that's actually not known very much is
Scott McNealy when he started son he
started as a VP of manufacturing I
didn't know that almost nobody knows
that
one point I said Scott you gotta become
our VP of Sales because of certain types
of behaviors but his background was in
manufacturing and you have to make those
cut cause it's a very non-intuitive gut
call so you have to make those but back
to this issue whose advice to trust and
what topic is the single hardest
decision and aren't know makes it's also
where the right investors can really
help you an argument just last week with
another co investor in a health care
company they wanted this health care
person who had never dealt with change
beyond 2% a year and I'm like experience
doesn't matter the rate of learning
matters first principles thinking
matters pick for the best athlete not
the person was the most established wide
receiver who knows how to run one
pattern and one pattern only but there's
two things I want to follow up on so
we'll get to the athlete in a second
we'll keep running into things yeah we
will um
howdy so I agree it's like really hard
to know whose advice to trust but a 20
year old entrepreneur comes in here no
work experience you decide to back them
you have to give him or her advice and
say here's how to do this what do you
say like how do you know whose advice to
trust tactically so I look at not what
entrepreneurs saying and we always have
this debate inside of them too but how
they're thinking about the problem in
first principles thinking if you give
them brand new problem so I'll often say
hey if you are doing this other startup
how do you approach it and if they have
to think from scratch on a brand new
problem and by the way this great
interview question that they've never
dealt with they don't have an experience
with how do they approach it is probably
the best indicator of how fast they will
learn if I pick between lots of
excellent learning how to trust
different people's judgment yep
including learning who to trust in which
people to trust and and so this becomes
sort of this nuance thing
you I'm sure you've noticed one things
we look at YC stuff in the three months
that were there that they've been that
YC what's their rate of change if we've
had multiple points of intercept right
that may be a stronger indicator than
any other single story number one right
that is my number one by far right so we
always say how fast did they evolve
their plan changed their plan what's
first saying to me with other investors
they say we'll stick to your plan or are
you executing in your plan and I'm the
exact opposite how fast are you evolving
your plan or changing your plan and
learning so my building that team that
can should this brings up a related
issue we should talk to since I want to
focus on people when you hire a VP of
Marketing and I've said this to you
before one question the functional
question is can he do marketing but
that's not the most important question
if he's one of the top five people in
the company the most important question
is what are the questions he will ask
how will he make the CFO better or the
VP of Engineering better through the
questions they ask which then prompt
this kind of thinking which then leads
to a better kitchen cabinet the people
you coalesce around your dining table
when you have a really hard ambiguous
uncertain decision to make and how do
you evaluate that in an interview you're
interviewing a VP of Marketing you want
to know if I'm gonna make the CFO better
well how do you probe that I'll often
say if you were to sue people often say
here's what happened at my company and
I'd say if you were CEO and you had to
make a different set of decisions what
we did you have them think under
circumstances or if you're doing this
other startup one of my favorite
questions in start-up world is if you if
I gave you ten million dollars today
what startup three startups would you
consider and what are the reasons as an
investor you wouldn't want to invest in
those like you suddenly get how they
think about a new problem which is what
you face every day in a star
yeah it really is true that the I think
one thing everyone underestimates when
they start a start-up is just how little
of the problem they've already thought
about and how much more is going to
reveal itself every week so I often tell
entrepreneurs a business plan is
completely irrelevant other than to
judge how somebody's thought about a
problem not what they're going to do
speaking of that how much do you expect
a founder to have figured out early on
and how like how ambitious should have
founder be like how ambitious were you
when you started son how much if son had
you figured out how much did that vision
stay true to what happened sure I'd say
I was very ambitious I'd done one other
startup before that was also pretty
successful Daisy systems and that went
on to go public in the 80s raised a
hundred million dollars which is a huge
IPO in those days so I was very
ambitious but because I was much more
passionate and passions and important
ingredient we should talk about
especially in the team I was passionate
about what I wanted to get done
not about RR or the returns or so I
liked founders who are very ambitious
mostly because if they're trying to if
they're not ambitious they'll hire a
team to build the zero million dollar
company if they're ambitious they'll
hire a team to build a billion dollar
billion dollar company so among the
first 15 people at Son 15 20 people we
hired Eric Schmidt who went on to run
Google I didn't know he was gonna be
that capable we hired Carol Bartz who
ran Autodesk and then Yahoo hired bill
joy who wasn't part of the initial
founding team we recruited him as a
founder after the fact we hired so many
other people guys like Tom lion and Bob
Lyon
each of which have started
billion-dollar companies
Larry garlic who nobody knows now who
started remedy which big like this
any vector chime himself has started so
many companies there was such an
incredible talent pool there so this I
really want to dig it on there's only a
small handful but the way you just want
to take one small diversion when I met
Andy that's he was in Margaret Jack's
Hall at Stanford he said why don't you
license the technology for ten thousand
dollars right and he had licensed it to
six other startups at ten thousand which
in the 80s for a graduate student was a
shitload of money in fact one of those
companies sibling was funded by kleiner
perkins and John doar was on the board
so but they took the license I said Andy
I want the goose that laid the golden
egg I don't really care about the golden
egg because it will be irrelevant in a
couple of years I didn't know why but
part of it was I just loved interesting
people but I gave him half the equity
just to join and then I did a sales job
and selling his incredible part of being
an entrepreneur into dropping his ph.d
now best decision I ever made best
decision he ever made but it was a hard
sales job to convince him I sort of say
in recruiting a noise maybe and maybe as
a yes and that's sort of my job and I
get very disappointed when I can't get
him yes how long did it take you to get
him from a node maybe yes a couple of
months but bill joy took six months
because I also had to convince him to
drop his PhD so two people drop their
PhDs the very best people I've ever
recruited in different ways in my career
have all taken at least months to
recruit yeah it takes wait because they
always have something great to walk away
yeah the people who don't have something
great to walk away are probably the
people you don't want absolutely yes you
know especially when you
thinking beyond dysfunctional in the
people who do job acts well whether it's
marketing or database architecture or
whatever or thinking linearly if they're
broad thinkers which is what's key to
that kitchen cabinet that helps you
evolve a plan you need people who's so
full of ideas they're always triaging
down to the thing they can do and people
like that always have great
opportunities so it's hard to get them
to join as an employee because they can
start there and you chase them forever
so this is actually what I wanted to go
to next there's a handful of companies
that have been able to get those people
in the early 10 20 30 employees that
could go start their own company and
that go on to later PayPal's the famous
example sons another one what did you do
it son and what has happened in other
companies where you've seen this where
people build this phenomenal early team
that goes on to be wildly successful
well it's always about you know
entrepreneurship is a funny thing
because vision is impractical if you're
reasonable you won't do unreasonable
things it's just by definition yep right
and and so if you have great managers
good process people they will work
against allowing the company to become
great they'll take a great idea and turn
it into a good one and execute a decent
idea at lower risk that's more
reasonable more sensible if you're
trying to end and that's okay goal to
have if that's your goal if your goal is
something unreasonable something
ambitious really visionary something
change the world then you have to take
the other approach get this think tank
of unreasonable people together and
below that layer the reasonable people
who micro optimize within the macro
ideas that the kitchen cabinet comes up
with how do you think about the equity
that it takes to step to attract these
kinds of people so I see this as a major
problem nowadays people aren't
allocating equity widely enough
I think among the first three or four
founders at Sun
we kept less than half of the common
which was just the total was something
like 25 to 27 percent for the founders
in equal a slightly larger chunk for
everybody else we would hire and then
investors had minority but a significant
minority so it was like 40 percent for
investors us after the around something
like that in retrospect that was a very
good idea so when last year my son
started his company I said keep 15
percent for yourself instead of 45 he
could have done either number try and
hire one or two people at 15% even
though they're coming later even though
they didn't come up with idea but that
would be incredible resources especially
magnets to attract other people or bring
essential skills can you say what you
mean by a magnet to attract other people
so if you believe a company becomes the
people it hires then your key task
becomes attracting the people there's
also using them productively that's a
management skill but attracting people
becomes who finds you attractive and
selling depends on magnets so bill joy
is an incredible magnet even back then
right and even though open-source didn't
exist the way it does today people
wanted to work with Bill and Andy and
even if bills didn't do a day of work he
was more than worth it because he helped
her attract Eric Schmidt
I don't think Eric would have come work
for me as a 25 year old other than I did
have self a convincing power of why this
was going to be large we discarded for
example the notion that which most
investors said why don't you be a
graphics add-on term nerd codec
access and that was established known
market there was no graphics terminal
there was a company in Utah evidence in
Southland that built graphics terminals
those easy.you ndu distributed computing
and nobody had heard the term when we
released NFS there was no distributed
file system in the world and we open
sources and people first said one who
needs distributed computing and the
second question was if it's important
why you giving away all your
intellectual property so thinking on the
specifics don't matter
thinking nonlinearly about it is what
matters and that's what the team enabled
right and and so full circle back to
equity as much as leaving 30% of the
pool to non founders so Neil took 15% he
recruited in in his other startup Keira
he kept 15% hired 15% a co-founder for
15% and then left the rest to hired
great employees now it is dependent on
the area you're working in he was
working in AI he wanted the people who
were all making million dollar salaries
at Google and uber and other places as
engineers so you had to give them three
four five percent each and you'd
normally not think about it but if
you're competing in an AI startup you're
not gonna get the best talent without
and especially if this issue we talked
about earlier if somebody can do their
own startup they will so they're not
comparing them to some your job you're
comparing them to them starting their
own company and so and if you don't do
that you're including only the people
who couldn't start their own company who
won't help you evolve we apply a thing
that I hear a lot is you know I could
hire an engineer for expert basis points
so why would I ever pay like 5x or 10x
and and then I always say like wait and
you know in two years ask me again
the right decision yeah but the quality
of people you can get if you're super
generous of equity I think this is the
shape of things to come I think that the
way this is my single biggest beef with
YC not enough option pool i right
not enough option pools not enough focus
on recruiting the right co-founders
right in I was fortunate Neil trusted me
so I could Shepherd him into sort of a
very different approach I think he may
have had the highest option pool in his
batch yeah look I think it's great I
have found that it's harder to convince
founders that this than I would have
expected yeah because it's not intuitive
well also most investors say make the
option pool as small as you can yeah
because neither investors nor founders
want to they'd like to own as much as
possible and it sounds really good and
until you felt it it's hard to convince
them but I'm or they won't like to own
the higher percentage but the pie is
much smaller and if you sort of say I'm
maximizing the size of the pie plus then
it doesn't matter what percentage you're
on
look I think this is this is the most
important piece of advice that we've
talked about among many important things
today
I think being super generous with early
employee equity and getting founder
quality people is the first 10 employees
I think all the evidence is on the side
of doing this and yet almost no one does
so there's like a huge edge if you're
willing to do it and absolutely a
hundred percent agreed that this ends up
being the single most important thing in
the first six months of a company and
and it's incredibly important in fact
I've written two pieces on one Wentz
once you're doing a start-up how do you
engineer the gene pool of a company and
and there's an important part you sort
of have to have a process you know I
find it silly to advise people to hire
the best team because everybody says
that it's not actionable but when you
processed to follow this process I
called gene pool engineering you are
trying to maximize your chances of
success and you're minimizing the risks
you're taking on by virtue of the team
you're building and that
one part of it and that's sort of more
mechanical the other part is instead of
functional hiding hide a VP of
engineering hire a VP of Marketing hire
a CFO hire PPO customer support you do
hiring for this nonlinear stuff how does
your VP of Marketing and improve the
quality of your VP of engineering make
them think harder this sort nonlinear
thinking is and I've written a different
piece called I think the labor of love
the art of hiring something like that on
our website that's a long piece about
this and both these were couple years
ago in TechCrunch also I think the
essential reading font knows in my view
even if they don't follow the advice
it'll change how they think about the
problem we will add the links to our
website one final question one area to
wrap up on we've talked a lot about how
to pick your employees your team members
I think it's almost as important to pick
your investor as well so how do you
advise founders if they're trying to
build a significant company that's going
to do something very disruptive be
around for decades how should they think
about their investors so I think every
piece of I puddi you do the money you
get is the smaller part of what you get
advice and the right approach is the
much more important part a simple time
there's investors who are happy with
three times their money in fact when a
sell as soon as they can and make 3 X 4
X and people who care about your vision
or people who understand the technical
logical approach you're taking and will
be much more tolerant as things go wrong
right so those are the factors I suggest
people optimize for and how do you tell
how do you know if an investor truly
cares about your vision talk to other
founders especially founders who've gone
through a large promise large vision and
had hiccups along the way when things go
wrong around an ambitious path is when
you can actually judge an investor how
they think about hiring look
back in retrospect couple years later or
talk to founders who can and say what
worked and what didn't like those aren't
the key questions I think an investor is
an employee who you can't fire and
that's how you should think about it
otherwise all the same principles apply
I get very frustrated with investors
because they mostly detract from value
like most investors are negative value
add to a company that's trying to be
ambitious if they're just trying to get
to liquidity as soon as possible
then there's plenty of investors who do
that well have you had founders who come
pitch in and say that's too ambitious
I've never had that happen I have had
the following conversation that's
ambitious that's awesome
build a team for it now what is step one
two and three and let's be thoughtful
about how you how you discover the risks
on the path to the vision because
frankly achieving a large vision is
first about discovering what's hard what
the problems are what else influences
success along that path once you've
found the problem and which you can only
discover by doing things then you can
the only recipe I've ever seen work for
making really impactful companies is
both a giant vision and a good step one
two and three yeah you have to have both
and neither without the other World War
I the related thing I often tweet this I
hate pontificate errs so easy to do
studies so easy to opine on things I
love doers versus pontificating each and
Nassim Taleb has written skin in the
game but also not so much black swuan
but his second book after that so skin
in the game is about doers versus
pontificate errs and then he has another
book about the right kinds of asymmetric
risks to take that he wrote after the
Black Swan that I feel is more important
than
one one thing that has just worked for
me again and again in my career is I
happen to like I love doers and I don't
love talkers and I just got lucky
because I biased the people I surround
myself with so far in that direction
it's been great final question what are
you most what do you hope to get down in
the next 10 years what are you most
excited about doing now so I'm 63 I
actually at 60 defined what I want to
work on for 20 years I wrote a piece
called
reinventing societal infrastructure with
technology it's about a 50 page document
and it was the following exercise and I
won't go into the details because we
don't have enough time I said if I took
the u.s. GDP what parts of the
non-governmental GDP cont Irene mind
personally with technology and I
expected addicts I'd come up with a
small part of the GDP that was open to
working on turns out there's no part of
non governmental huge US GDP that one
came in a wait on in ways that not 5 10
% improvements but our hundred to a
thousand percent improvements in
resources notes so I sort of decided if
7 billion people on the planet want the
lifestyle that 700 million people the
top 10% have and that 10% has an energy
rich lifestyle a health care rich style
education rate lifestyle a
transportation rich you get the idea the
very rich lifestyles without destroying
the planet could be get seven billion
people to seven that lifestyle of the
700 million people then without
destroying the planet and without
needing 10x of everything could you do
it and I could think of a way to do it
in every major part personally only
thing I'm sure is entrepreneurs and so I
subtitled this document a call to
entrepreneurs it's amazing because no
part of the GDP is immune to innovation
five six years ago when when Pat Brown
said he wanted to eliminate animal
husbandry became very clear we could
change how most of this planets the
usable land area is used most of the
land on this planet and that's Pat's
mission and we I think I said yes to him
in our very first meeting we didn't last
I didn't even need to know the details
it was just a vision too big to not
attempt so hamburgers to rocket labs
doing rockets which we did about the
same time to my new passion could you
build buildings with eighty percent less
material that's why I'm so excited about
printed 3d printed buildings like
there's nothing from food to building to
construction to rockets to or everything
computation enables from AI to it's it's
really exciting and I feel like twenty
years not gonna be enough I hope I stay
healthy I hope you do too I'm sure you
will that's a great place to leave it
people can read that document and call
you up yeah thank you very much thanks
thanks Sam this fun